I don't have music or anything we just
go alright great hey what's up everybody
this is Dave fails we are at all things
comedy I'm Kate Quigley yes this is
gonna be a really fun episode I'm super
pumped for this one I have a couple on
the show today I've never had a couple I
have two awesome guests today and one of
the things I love about this show is
sometimes they have comics on that like
we've done shows together and I see you
guys out but I don't really feel like
I've ever gotten to know you otally you
know this is almost like a first date
like that yeah yeah so let me introduce
my guest first of all I have your
beautiful Halle larious we just did a
show together a few weeks ago this girl
killed it you also like me hosted the
AVN Awards on Showtime 2014 right yes we
definitely have to talk about that she
tours all over the place Rebecca coach
and everyone and then also this guy you
have about a billion TV credits I can't
even name properties all right most
notably at Last Comic Standing and can I
say that when I was I did a little
research on you guys and I thought your
most interesting credit which I need to
talk about is you have on your website
that you've won the most beta1 I was
super famous on Black Entertainment
Television I had my own sitcom I was on
a show called comic view every day of
the week if you watched it I was on it
like Dante the comic everyone first of
all Dante the comment but that sounds
like a black card when I go up on stage
because a lot of times people show even
like introduce me to say he's been on B
et blah blah blah please welcome Dante
they see me come up and I swear to God
clapping will stop as I enter the stage
like they're assuming the managers the
black comic is running late hilarious a
that I just go are you guys assuming
that I was black because of all the bTW
you should come up sometime and just
pretend to be the club manager just keep
calling him the black I guess the black
comics not coming so how did that happen
that you became like such a huge B et
star the 90s were black comedy was huge
Nathan and it's like if you didn't do it
it's your own fault because there was
money to be made the King a shit-ton 'm
can I say [ __ ] him you can say anything
like it was so different than going to
like a white comedy club white comedy
club you make X amount for like five
days four days three days depending on
where you go black room they would fly
you in first-class limousine you would
play a theater like 2,000 people no way
hand you a bag of cash not a check a bag
of cash you know what I like about black
clubs even cuz it's funny the first club
I ever got paid at to do stand-up was
the J spot nice have you been there you
guys been there it's in Inglewood is the
blackest room in a Larry Brown yes Jan
13 straight
it's literally like it's like going to a
gospel church I mean that's how you feel
but the audience well cuz that's the
thing they dress up like when they come
out black people at least at least they
are dressed to the nines
black people and gay people spend money
for entertainment and love entertainment
yes totally
and Latinos like best audiences in the
world gay black Latino I couldn't agree
more that's why I love the Ontario
improv because it's a good mix of yackin
Mexican and it's fantastic it's like my
favorite place to play so well that's
cool that you're a black superstar
before we get into anything I want to
let you guys plug what you have coming
up I think you well would be if you
anyone in Denver we're gonna be at the
Denver improv on December 20th through
the 23rd so come out it's gonna be an
excellent time and we're gonna be at the
Laugh Factory in Reno for New Year's the
whole week we're there the 27th through
January 1st so come see us it's inside
the silver legacy in Reno and then we're
doing the dirty where we played with you
yeah we're going back to the AVN's with
my clients poor client I have some porn
clients I have porn clients and that's
how I also am a manager because I work
one hour a day and I like business and I
like using people's careers and making
money at it yeah but anyway so we're
going there for the AVN Awards but we're
also playing the dirty which is a great
show yeah just so you guys know the
dirty at 12:30 is a show at South Pointe
casino Friday nights in Las Vegas at
like 12:30 at night and it's my favorite
show got voted best show best free show
in Las Vegas it's amazing I mean it's
arguably like cuz the thing about it is
all the headliners just pop and you spa
huge names every black yeah in any given
night you could see like Joe Rogan shows
up and does 10 minutes people just pop
in it's such a good room yeah it is -
Wow
there was something else I was gonna say
about the AVN's I'm bummed I'm not gonna
be there this year
I'm actually working that weekend with
Joey Diaz in Scottsdale Irvine Tempe
where are we going Tempe improv Tempe
improv I love him yeah he's the best
I love him as well but no there was
something I was gonna say about the
AVN's damn it'll come back to me Rebecca
yeah you hosted the a/v animals yes
that's our like thing that we have
together we were both avian hoes I know
so how did it happen for you I um I did
a spot at the Comedy Store and I
actually like I bombed it was horrible
true that's not true she didn't she was
on a showcase where everyone else was
keeping it clean she
little dirty yeah they weren't feeling
it though and so this guy came up to me
afterwards and he's like I thought you
were really funny and I was like oh
thanks whatever and then literally like
nine months later that guy calls and
says he wants her and it was great right
yeah that's how and we had to meet Gary
Miller who says I don't trust you I
don't want you to know you you could be
terrible I don't know yeah Gary Miller
is this guy who produces the AVN's
god bless him god bless nicely yes nice
guy I think he produces porn also I
don't know I kind of heard that I kind
of heard that like I'd be surprised yeah
but he is the ultimate nagger when it
comes to world I'm not yeah because like
he hired me for the I got hired for the
job him and another guy from Showtime
came out to see me at Ventura harbor
club and then they asked me if I want to
do it and the funny thing is I don't
even know what it was I'm not kidding
they're like you know hosts AVN Awards
and I was like what is that like a bird
show like I literally had no idea but so
they they were like we just think you're
really funny and we want you know we
want like a girl we want an attractive
woman whatever and then like but then
after they hired me he kept telling me
like how lucky I was you know I know it
was like he always said the worst [ __ ]
to me like the day of the show like some
woman came to like do my makeup and
stuff yeah he said to the girl who came
in my hotel room he goes now look you
need to make her look like a hot chick
and then after the show she can go back
to doing whatever it is that she does
the rest to me when he called me to tell
me that they want to do super hot or
whatever he goes just so you know you
can't like where you're playing
and do your usual a butch out thing that
you do okay I think I could you could
accomplish that I think you have to wear
a dress to wear a dress it's so funny
because it's like what does you think
you're gonna do go on Showtime and like
cargo pants and a play and alright
because people always go on national
television just wearing a flannel all
the time and the whole time he's just
telling you bits that he loves that he
wrote you know what one guy's gonna that
these people are gonna be making out and
he's gonna come out in a dress and she's
gonna be in a tuxedo and they're gonna
go oh I guess we put on the wrong
clothes everyone's gonna love it we
heard about this every day every day
story can I tell you guys the one thing
that happened that oh god I know like
that probably listen to this and then
I'm gonna get like an angry email or
something but I gave them you know they
here I gave him my jokes like I told him
a lot of the jokes I was gonna do before
the show and and what's so funny is I
had jokes about incest you know and like
rape joke and like a Charlie Sheen's
AIDS joke and all these jokes and then
the one joke he didn't want me to do is
I had a joke about Donald Trump
it was just like there's a new word this
year the award for biggest dick
surprisingly a black actor wasn't
nominated but that's because the only
nominee is Donald Trump right right I
gave that to him and he goes you know we
don't think you should do the Donald
Trump joke because porn stars are
actually really conservative and we
don't think it's gonna work it's not so
weird because they are like you meet a
lot of them that are like very
conservative Christian and you're like
dude you like how anal for a living
super super weird there's so many
happily married couples important to
children I don't get it I don't get it
oh my god did I tell you that I played a
Mensa convention recently and I was the
nine o'clock show and there was an 8:30
thing in the ballroom next door that I
had to compete with and the 8:30 thing
was parenting after porn parenting after
corn Adam meant a convention by the way
because that's what the Mensa folks are
looking for parenting after porn and it
was taught by this couple and I swear to
God
not means up there's a guy and a girl
the girl had a stump leg she was an
amputee and you're lying she specialized
in porn where people would [ __ ] her with
her own leg that's amazing that they I
mean she probably had purposely has some
kind of you know stump leg that's easy
to be inserted yeah what's in other
people I think that the stump leg sex
toy conversation is a perfect time to
introduce to get sex toys I don't
believe that they sell stump legs that
you can use yet which is fine because
you know I'm not sure that's a popular
fetish although we could probably turn
it into one your on date fails but I do
want to give a shout out I'm very
excited about Adam Eve calm because
everyone knows I love lingerie and I
love vibrators and Adam and Eve has both
and they also have all kinds of other
things lotions and lube and we have a
fabulous deal going on right now there
is a coupon code which is date
da-te as in date fail if you go put in
date at checkout you get 50% off just
about any item in the store and when you
select one item at 50% off you also
receive three free adult DVDs plus a
free mystery gift and to top it all off
even free shipping on your entire order
so I know they could probably get some
of your clients films you want to give
any of your clients a shout out on you
[Music]
I want to have him on his Donald Trump
Donald Trump impressions funny and so is
Ron I was so impressed
Ron is really yeah I take on clients I
don't I don't book them in in porn at
all I take them on to put them in things
like I've gotten Ron in probably 20
movies this year and BuzzFeed and all
these other things so that's what I like
to do with them get them in movies and
whatever but yeah he is brilliant I
really Evan stone is actually really
funny and he does stand-up too just like
Ron I've met Evan so many times I
annoyed I hope he doesn't take offense
this I don't watch tons of porn okay I
didn't know he was a porn star I just
thought he was a Donald Trump
impersonator porn for forever he had
this long Wow Wow well there you go guys
so is it adamandeve.com and okay so now
let's get into it with you two I'm
fascinated by you guys oh good first of
all I have like a no dating comics rule
because I've done it and [ __ ] it up
show me - it's a weird thing to do yes
but you guys are both comics yes how
long have you guys been together almost
10 years oh we're not married yet we
want to get married we're I mean like
we're married except we don't have a she
has a nice ring a nice ring on because I
think it's unfair that a woman has to
wear a ring and a man doesn't so this
way women know I'm taken even if I'm not
so wait you guys you guys are not
married but you both wear ring so you
basically act like you're married under
the paperwork right which we plan on
getting married this orders want to get
married yes totally it's just a matter
of we were we were originally waiting
for gay marriage to pass I knew I say
that yeah yeah yeah we were originally I
was like I don't wanna get married well
then as soon as it passed everyone was
like are you getting married now I'm
like yeah but not we're not planning a
date immediately so we waited a couple
years I didn't realize you guys have
been together 10 years
holy [ __ ] since I was
not that you don't look young Dante's
young I met her when she was young I'm
not gonna lie did you date guys before
him no I'm 32
so when I met him you know when I was 22
but I had lived I also left home when I
was 17 so from like 17 to 22 I was
living hard and fast let me tell you how
fun Las Vegas loved her she was just
done with school and was 17 and wanted
out
right it's fine if your mom hated you my
mom hated me so no one's judging you
here okay okay move to when you're 17 I
moved I got a studio apartment in Los
Feliz and I worked at PF Changs and
that's what I did when I first moved
here but yes but I mean I was I mean
like I had a full life between 17 and
when I met Dante for sure oh you did oh
yeah did it Arina am i allowed to dig
into that or talk about anything - I
don't care wait you dated a lot between
17 and 22 any serious boyfriends during
that time oh oh just lots of dating lots
of dating that's so good that's why you
guys are good cuz you got it out of your
systems that it mean maybe it's a really
shitty girlfriend when we first got to
because I'd never dated I was like
nothing about dating or being in a
monogamous relationship because I never
done it he's your only one he's in my
only monogamous relationship ever yeah
it was really bad at it I was what do
you mean like what shooting that she
I'll give you a good example
we've their star
dating we went out with her and some of
her friends hung out all night me and
this guy are hanging out on her bed at
the end of the night we're talking best
friends I give him my number we
exchanged numbers and then he leaves and
this girl comes in and goes wow you're a
great boyfriend I've never seen any
boyfriend cool with hanging out with her
ex-boyfriend before I was like she don't
even tell me he didn't tell me I'm
hanging out on her bed with this guy she
never had one he was just a guy she this
was the guy she was with for forever you
dated him more than anyone else for a
longer period than anyone else yeah but
I was never to monogamy are you suppose
to tell what who you've been with or if
you yes you know what I mean like you
got your tongue out many times no no we
were dating we know I mean that guy was
your first time meeting him that night
yeah you're saying she should have given
you like a little heads-up like hey by
the way I dated this guy we went on a
comedy tour do you know Shaima Tosh yeah
okay she was my girlfriend before she
even got into comedy a long long time
okay so Shaima became a comic we were
gonna go on tour one time and it was
like five people doing military stuff
right then we and I'm like oh man shame
is on the show so now I have to explain
to her who she is and make her
comfortable you know and we show up on
this tour and the two of them got along
better than I got you know but if I
didn't tell her that
and then Shaima was like you know and
Dante and I were dating she would have
freaked out that's that's rude good
point yes that's a fair point you guys
were dating for a while you probably
should have - okay that's fair if you're
dating for one I don't know cuz I mean
like for instance I had I had a birthday
party recently yes you guys were there
yes and
I would thank you I was um I was really
uncomfortable because a lot of guys
showed up that I either had hooked up or
was currently kind of dating I didn't
know that we're all gonna be there like
a couple I invited the former's you know
I had invited but I didn't really think
they'd come and then they did and then
there's one that I'm
keine seeing who my friend accidentally
sort of mentioned it to so then he
showed up and then there was one I
actually invited that I wanted to Congo
but then it's and I didn't know what to
do so I just avoided all of them that
was the only option
oh my god anyone walked in that I never
slept with or made out with I was like
thank you God a lot of them comics no no
I had two comics that were there I've
made out west but I've never had sex
with so first I went through a little
phase where I would like make out with
comics you know I like be out get drunk
we'd make out but thank god I've only
slept with a couple and I liked those
two a lot so no I'm just kidding
actually one I was like crazy about we
dated for like a year and I was so into
him well it was just like you know when
you date someone that you know the whole
time you should stop but the sex is so
good that you can't stop so that guy we
eventually realized though that we would
murder each other if we kept dating so
we stopped but I think both of us like
still to this day when we see each other
we still want to [ __ ] but we just we
avoid each other so that we don't [ __ ]
that's how it is now that's smart though
that's a mature adult thing to do well
the truth is he just won't [ __ ] me
I begged comic not want to find a ting
so no I would no I won't first of all
he's crazy but we're all comics sure the
truth is that he and I made you there so
I we have blocked and unblocked each
other's numbers at least a dozen times
me in this guy like we are either like
super passionate or want to murder each
other no joke Wow so whenever I'm not
seeing anyone or whenever I am not
sleeping with anyone and I'm really in
the mood I'll still hit him up but now
this is how it goes like I'll send him a
text I'll just go hey you up and he'll
write back no
I'll go like hey what are you doing
tomorrow and he'll go we're not [ __ ]
he literally won't do it he won't do it
the nuttiest everyone no need you must
have out-crazy to him that's probably
what happened you had to about crazy
there's no a man to turn down his own
penis we were crazy but they're really
sorry I really like you but I mean we're
both crazy
we're both sooo did you do something he
was like I can't believe you [ __ ] did
do you know what he told me to do
another truth yes okay this is what he
told me but I don't know if it's true or
not he he told me one night a comedy
club this wasn't that long for like a
year and a half we didn't speak and then
finally we kind of started talking
casually in public and then he told me
one night he goes look I know I was
insane with you he goes but here's the
thing I know it's not fair
say no we were never exclusive and I
know I was always [ __ ] other people
but I kind of liked you and when I would
see like all the other comics that hit
on you it would really bother me and in
my head I would think you were [ __ ]
everyone and so like he goes I can't
just [ __ ] you and not give a [ __ ] what
you're doing but I also don't want to be
with you so we just can't [ __ ] that
makes good sense yeah and I think you
know I really liked you but he's not
ready to commit to anybody and it hurts
too much to like you I mean that's his
that's what he said by that I buy that
that I sense I think he has a girlfriend
that has to be it no guy turns down sex
if you really like someone jealousy is a
beast it's a beast like I get it I get
it because I yeah I mean look how
jealous you were of her ex that was
sitting on the bed with you that I
actually wasn't jealous I was just tell
me ya know with them I just wanted to
know yeah that's all just tell me I
don't care I've hung out with lots of
her ex-boyfriend nobody not yeah I'm
friends I'm one of my best friends is
her ex-boyfriends best friend like I'm
jealous guy I only get jealous if
someone makes me jealous yeah you know
well that's the thing and that's why
it's so hard to date comics I feel
especially is the man because like
here's the thing like for you it's
probably not as bad cuz you know he
loves you he's not gonna cheat on you
right
but like guys know if he sees another
comic talking to you he automatically
knows that guy's trying to bang you cuz
there's no reason guys talk to women if
they're not
that's not always true but I get what
you're saying but yeah I just want to
[ __ ] every girl and they don't care if
you have a boyfriend or not correct
right girls now it's they'll even take
sitting in a car with you alone for 20
minutes as something great life right
and if you're nice to a man then they
think that like you want to [ __ ] them
because that's obviously how it works
and then there's that whole vicious
cycle that was one of our issues in the
beginning because there would always be
some comic usually the opening act
who wouldn't offer me weed but all the
sudden would go off in a car with her
for like a half-hour while I was on
stage and smoke weed and I'm like no
it's weird to me no I know I was know
worst when we got to worse it was the
worst girlfriend in the history of
girlfriends and we first got together
because I had no idea how to be in any
sort of relation yeah so I was horrible
you had to learn yeah right I I
eventually just said look just you're
gonna have guy friends do whatever you
want just don't give away our
relationship power you know what I mean
if I was to buy you a drink and you can
tell he's hitting on you
just say you I'll give you all my money
you could you can buy whatever you want
you know what I mean I'll take that is
being nice I wants to buy you a drink
let him buy you a drink
like I don't care it's just if you you
can tell if a man's hitting on you and
trying to like hook up with you or if
he's just being nice I mean see now this
is interesting because I used to think
that until guys all drilled it into my
head that no guy buying a drink for you
is ever just being nice but if I bought
you a drink it would just be me being of
course cuz I know your girl though
that's right I know it that doesn't mean
anything
I can't tell you how many comics I've
been on the road with I won't say one
name where all they do is [ __ ] five
women and we pull up to the airport and
there's their wife and kids waiting for
him that's true but I'm I'm such a
girl's girl I was just talking to
someone about this it's funny cuz like
people think I'm such a guys check cuz I
love a lot of my friends are guys and I
like sports so people assume I'm like a
guy's chick but I'm such a girl's girl
when it comes to like if I know your
girl I would even if I don't know your
girl fine oh you have a girl I would
never in a million years even like touch
a dish as a girlfriend because like if
someone did that to me
yeah I wanna stab right right you know
so I would never do that but I'm also a
good boyfriend like if I go on the road
I sure she can call me even if I'm on
stage like there's you know a lot of
comics I don't care I'll be like honey
I'm in the middle of a show people the
audience would love that joke or
something you guys have been together 10
years and you still have this yeah I
know I'm madly in love with her and I
never thought I would get married like
really I never thought I would be able
to be in like a healthy functioning
relationship really never and like I
think Dante is the only person that I
could have had that with this is the
opposite of date I think that that's why
we connect is because we figured out
what we hated and other people right
don't you think so many date fails so
many okay great let's hear them I want
to here are some of the worst though I
could go on for so long I don't even
know where to be sadly one of the people
is probably listening to this show and
you probably know her maybe there's a
girl I dated right before Rebecca and it
just got weird it got weird it got weird
I want to hear about it wait so it's a
comment yeah so you've dated a lot of
common oh I dated two comics yeah he
really has only dated two and the other
comic Shaima wasn't even a comic when I
did she wasn't a comic that she was a
dealer in San Diego at a casino
she's hot yes she came out to my show we
started dating and oh okay that kind of
ended poorly because she was sick one
night I stayed at her house to like keep
her healthy I stayed up watching TV with
her friend in the morning she was very
jealous at the time but she was like in
fairness she was like young 18 yeah she
thought I slept with her friend that
night she was also in a fevery coma or
whatever but just stop see we've been
friends since that day but that's why we
kind of stopped seeing each other oh wow
the other one it's I don't know you
better tell some your stories I have to
figure out if I can even you can tell
this well if there's she's probably not
listening I wonder now I don't know I
don't know who it is but I doubt many
comics listen to my job alright so
there's a female comic that I dated
right before Rebecca and I I think we
had sort of the same thing it was a
crazy relationship where it's like we
enjoyed hanging out with each other but
then I was also almost too afraid to
leave because it was so crazy you know
what I mean I was afraid of what she
would do because even when I was being
nice to her she would act like I
destroyed her like one night traumatic
right Dante has a thing for crazy Jews
like everyone has a thing for every guy
is thing for crazy women maybe that's
what guys love crazy or attracted to
Dante like here's a good example of
crazy I just bought this nice white
dinner jacket I am running Vitelli or is
this okay it was like 10 years ago okay
anyway I was running Vitello's comedy
night with this guy who just passed away
Mel Cole and this girl that I was dating
she wanted to go up on the show and
there was an agent in the room and I
said when do you want to go up she was I
want to go up right before you or
something like that soon as she gets off
stage she had a bad set she came up to
me with her wine threw it all over me
through the glass down broke it and
starts screaming in the middle of
Vitello's oh my god a bad set that i
sabotaged her who all I did was say
where do you want to go up and she goes
you knew I shouldn't have been in that
[ __ ] spot what yeah this is the thing
though it's like mixing business and
pleasure so like if she wasn't a comic
then that kind of [ __ ] probably wouldn't
happened right right see you guys
it was also a bad situation I was like
going through divorce stuff and she
wanted me to get out of my marriage
sooner and I was like I'm separated I'll
be done with it when I'm done with it
you know I shouldn't even be seen it was
a lot of drama I hate to say it it was a
lot of a lot of drama and look she's
probably a great person we just we
should it we were water and vinegar or
whatever it is it's like man I have him
saved my phone is not-- he's still my
opening joke I say I have a guy I've
been texting with a guy I've saved my
phone is no and the joke still works
because we still attack so it's been
like four years actually about three and
a half years now it has been just we
haven't had sex in two years and we
still text back and forth and like
sometimes we'll start flirting like
we're gonna hook up again and now you
gets to that point we'll start fighting
and so now for the last like six months
we've just been texting as friends we
decided he decided always remind to you
if you whisper yours to me but if you
don't want to yeah he has to have a
girlfriend I'm telling you this guy has
to have a girlfriend he has to write yes
any time ago me an age range I'll tell
you who he is after the show I'm like
going mad she's like 34 35 okay okay cuz
I've been going through the head I'm
like oh my god who is this mystery man
that she is talking I'll tell you guys
[Music]
hold on do you have you were married yes
marry he was married for how long I was
on a bad date for 44 oh my god yeah no
you're you look fantastic first of all
thanks and so that means you got married
when you were like 18 or yeah young I
was like 21 something like that and you
stayed in it for 15 17 years um yep and
we have a beautiful daughter which is
worth it she's a roller derby girl her
name is willow she's a junior Derby
dolly she's 13 yeah she's like a killer
on a team she's the jammer she's the one
that always beat the [ __ ] out of each
other like you see little girls just go
flying through the air and it's like
terrifying and hilarious she likes to be
girly but likes rough things like yeah
likes derby doll right she's match on
all of her makeup gets as pretty as
possible she did that the other day just
to go skateboarding at the park like a
supermodel skateboarding at the park man
that is so cool Rebecca do you and her
get along totally close because she was
little when we got together so I mean
like I've been a part of her life her
stepmom oh yeah
is she a new voice yeah I was hoping she
was gonna be a lesbian just because I
don't want her to have to deal with men
you know what I mean oh there are the
worst the men are
I will gladly tell every mam secret if
you need to know every man secret like I
will go on the road and a guy will go I
will hear him on his phone with his wife
going honey there is no phone in the
hotel and my cell phone is not getting
serviced I am you know 15 minutes away I
had to drive 15 minutes way just to make
this call I'm going to bed and he's in
his hotel room making this call next to
the phone let's be by his bed
of course yeah I mean I know I've
witnessed but here's the thing though is
that women are fault and I like I talked
about this on stage is we hear these red
flags and we ignore them always totally
I was on a first date with a guy that I
ended up really being into we dated for
like nine months and on the first day I
should have listened and we ignore the
[ __ ] on the first date he told me a
story about one night when he had a
girlfriend and he was out with his
roommate and he's flirting with some
chick at a bar and he went home and he
was in bed with his girlfriend at his
apartment and his roommate came back and
was like hey man I brought the chick
from the bar back for you and he was
pissed at his roommate not for doing it
but for doing it without checking first
to see if his girlfriend was there and
he told me this story I should have been
like this guy's a cheater
okay but at the time I was like well
maybe he'll just be a fun following
maybe it's not a big deal and then of
course I ignored it and ended up
catching feelings for him and having
like my heart broken right know I women
can ignore anything if they want to like
she didn't trust me at first because I
was dry through a divorce I was dating
that other comic and now I'm breaking up
with the other comic still going through
the divorce and madly in love with this
one and she was like no god no
you're you know and I just I had to
prove myself over and over right and
then finally I did and then she turned
into bad girlfriend in her early 20s
that's probably why you stayed though
right because I feel like the fact that
she was bad girlfriend is probably the
reason you kept chasing her cuz the nice
guys feel like they've got you they give
up trying oh yeah then we shouldn't get
married or else you're gonna be don't
get married
No
you already have attack yeah I know I
know exactly I would hear more about the
the thirteen year old being into boys
though like what is this oh my god she's
she'd be so mad if she knew what we were
talking about this right yeah yeah no
she but yeah she's totally into boys and
I'm just like no she was into this boy
that I had like pink hair dyed his hair
pink was like super punk rock I was like
really I don't care I've always told her
look if these boys are nice I'll be nice
to them if someone comes to the door and
was like hey dude is willow here I'll be
like slam willow get your stuff I'm
taking you to a movie you know cuz that
guy's not getting in my house wait you
call me dude slam I was so confused I'm
like where did he go wrong but you're
cool with the idea of like her dating I
don't care I don't care that's why she's
so smart she can do whatever she wants
she's you know she's very smart right
and I don't mean book smart I just mean
like she don't swear I know she also is
but she's not going to let some guy [ __ ]
her oh no she's not and I spent my whole
life telling her every man trick always
like what what are some and romantic man
tricks like what I said if a man says
that there's no phone at a hotel he's
full of [ __ ] if a man here's a here's a
great one ladies listen to this if and
this women do this too you're on the
phone with someone right and he says
hold on there's another call he clicks
back and you go who's that and he's like
oh it's a friend anyway what were you
saying if it was his if there was a male
he would have said that was Mike my
friend Mike right if it's a woman you
you say it's my friend and you move on
women do that too they're like oh that
was just my friend anyway what were you
saying but they don't want to say those
tricky tricky yeah that's a real trick
that's a good it's just like this it's
like if you're trying to make plans with
a guy and he says I can't have plans
that means he has another date but if he
says like oh I can't I'm going to the
races with Mike yeah they always explain
it when it's a guy if it's a chick
they're always like oh I can I'm busier
I play right because if he was doing a
gig or something he would say I'm at The
Improv tonight
whatever that's why I always tell guys
no matter what I'm doing I'm illusive
and I just say plans even if it's with
girls I want to keep them guessing yeah
totally I don't to play games but I also
don't want to give away my hand too soon
I have a bad habit of that let me ask
you something
what what I see is your brand is that
you are the fun funny single girl right
would a relationship [ __ ] that up
yes yeah cuz I've seen all part of your
fun brand yeah you know it's funny is I
think for me that's the and I was gonna
ask you guys about this kind of that's
the caveat for me with dating is that
yeah a lot of my brand has been built on
being like single and having fun and
making these mistakes and I am at a
point where I want to kind of try to
meet someone I start think but then
again every time I meet a nice guy that
really is into me and once more I'm the
one to run away I meet guys that will
never commit to me and I fall for them
cuz they won't commit I know I
that's what women do that though you
always I'm sure they know right every
win will chase you
that's why a lot of like I have some
girlfriends that will be like this guy
he'd never I'm like did you sleep with
him right away yes well he's done
hunting you that's it nice done hunting
right yeah if you had to hunt you for a
while you know or whatever but the
minute the Hunts over it's interesting
though because even after you sleep with
them if you lose interest they'll start
over chasing you again
right but the problem is it's like
that's so much work to have to keep
pretending not to be into someone
forever because that seems to be the key
is to act like you don't my friend says
whoever cares less wins I don't want to
care less you know you don't have to
care you know what I would suggest to
women let men impress you like let him
take you out on a real [ __ ] date like
women don't make men take them out
places anymore that's a good point I
know a girl who's like and we're just
going to a coffee shop and I'll pay for
mine he'll pay for his I'm like now let
him impress you let him take you out see
if he opens the [ __ ] door let him be
a man you know what I mean and if he if
he has to chase you like that and it
takes him a month to sleep with you
you'll have him around your finger for
life that's true
for life you know I have to say that
opening the door thing is very charming
and guys don't do it enough anymore even
car door I know like I did the guy who
would always open my car door and I got
so used to it that I recently went on a
date with another guy who was a really
nice guy but he didn't open my car door
and I was like oh yeah I was so turned
off you know I think I might expect too
much now though after ten years ten
years didn't you notice today when we
came in I ran ahead of you two to go
open that door you did I know he's so I
stand when she gets up in a restaurant
well she she goes to the bathroom I
stand up you two I stand up when she
gets back
even if we're out with her parents I
don't care I'll be the only man in the
restaurant doing it I don't care I'm
showing her respect he's a good man I
got really lucky
really but it's he dirty in bed yeah cuz
that's the thing is I tired to find a
guy that's a gentleman who's really
dirty in bed
oh he's dirty yeah you guys get two now
that I know that your kid might be
listening I she's alright she's cool
she's hopefully she's studying for
finals because that's what she's
supposed to be doing instead of
listening to fire there's no way she's
listening okay okay thank God I was you
know I I do have this is I'm using you
guys almost more for relationship advice
that we usually I try to make this all
super funny but like you guys are the
first couple I've ever had on it's
actually successful which is interesting
I had one other I'll tell a real story
oh my god I hope he doesn't get mad one
time when glickman Stephen Kramer
Glickman was co-hosting with me we had
on Jonathan Lipnicki the kid from Jerry
Maguire he does jujitsu in his great
body and he's a nice guy really nice guy
is he's still super cute like cute yeah
he's very cute yep he's very cute but he
came on and he showed up with his
girlfriend and it was so awkward because
she was like sitting she wasn't on the
show but she's like sitting on the couch
so we couldn't really get him to say too
much because it wasn't like they hadn't
been together that long and then they
left and then he text me like a couple
days later and he's like yo you know
sorry if the podcast is a little weird
we actually I got a huge fight on the
way there and then we broke up like the
next day like not only like broke up
because of your show
she's like why ever you told me that
story
jinx now that's the only time we ever
had a couple in the room together and
the next day's we'll be fine we'll be
fine the click man I used to be best
friends shut the [ __ ] up forever
nothing nothing who knows I don't know
we you know people people just get busy
and get apart yeah he's the best
but uh what I was gonna ask you is you
guys work together you know I had my
ex-husband die we work together and I
was married for ten years and we worked
together on the road for like five years
I would he wasn't a comic he would
produce events and I would emcee so he
was kind of behind the scenes and I was
like talent you know but uh for us it
became like we almost became colleagues
or business partners and it kind of like
the romance for us the romance kind of
died a lot of couples meet through work
and work together so I'm curious like
how you guys keep it going and work
together and managed to do it all can I
tell you what I think the secret is yeah
this is the true secret everybody is
looking for butterflies that's why you
want a first date to go well that's why
it's fun to make out on a first date
never let that go away you have to tell
yourself it's like when you buy a car
and you love that car so much and then
like a year later you're like I kind of
like that car better keep loving your
car like like I wake up every day
grateful that I'm laying next to her and
I tell her first thing in the morning I
always say it's a beautiful day and
you're the most beautiful woman in the
world that's what I say to you right
everything every seriously yeah I wake
her up I know I know I know I know I
know I would be is like a romantic
comedy everyday right
yummers of glickman I'll tell you this
story afterwards yeah how we met Oh
through Glickman he's supposed to be
like crazy and damaged and suicidal I am
you just did it name the damaged one but
you know it is it really is like making
sure that you're happy with that person
every day like to me the key to I always
tell my daughter it's love happiness
health safety and freedom love happiness
health safety freedom if you have those
five things you'll be a very happy
successful person if you're missing some
of those or you let someone else take
that away from you you're less happy
right mm-hmm
yeah can you see the shock on my face
you look shocked I'm guy that's like you
guys have been together ten years and
he's still like it has in love with you
as Dave wine madly he's crazy about like
identical to you friend of ours in Reno
with you that's how I kind of started
knowing your name he goes it was Dylan
oh yeah when you Dylan Riley came to see
at the Laugh Factory and he's like yeah
and he had a picture next to you and
that's how I got to know you
Oh a couple years ago or whatever yeah
was through him at first and then all of
a sudden you ended up on my Twitter feet
and this yeah that's when I contacted
yeah that's so crazy
yeah I'm trying to get better about it
actually I brought a guy to my birthday
party what a couple party that like I
want to give a chance to and he ended up
talking to one of my very very best guy
friends for like an hour and after and
this guy is like we're so close and he
never approves of anybody I date like he
doesn't think anyone yeah usually I date
guys he's like you know that one's just
a fling right like you can't stay with
that one but that he was honest yeah so
honest but he this guy he was like you
know what he has my approval he's a good
dude and I was like what I was so
shocked makes you hate him even more
doesn't it push him away faster well the
thing with this one is he I don't know
because I don't he's got a little edge
to him that's keeping me interested you
know what it is
he doesn't um he doesn't treat me it's
not he doesn't kiss my ass or
give me too many compliments or like the
way guys normally try so hard he kind of
makes fun of me in a way that I that
makes me feel like he's not that into me
good but I know yes right but I like
that you seem happy it's not like you're
out there like I need a boyfriend he's
like you're happy and having fun you
know what I mean like maybe this is just
what you're supposed to be doing right
now you don't need to be in guys are
idiots though right they think when they
tell you you're pretty that they're the
first one that ever told you like it's
always nice to have a compliment though
like I don't I don't want to say like
women don't want to hear that because of
course like horse it's the best but if
there's a balance you know it's like
don't don't like tease us all the time
but sometimes it's fine like just like
guys like it when a girl like gives you
shit-faced yeah I mean it's it's it's
all a game that we play right Rebecca
your face right now you're just like
you're just looking at him like you I
feel like you must give him a lot of
[ __ ] and go what did that lady do that
night before we get out of here I mean
you kind of already touched on it but I
always ask everyone like if they have a
worst date story or worst sex story
about you I I have a pretty bad date
story I was probably like 20 21 I met
this guy at a bar and he asked me out so
we went on a date and he told me he can
he's one of those people that have that
power that if they're holding like a rod
they can tell if there's water under
what underground have you heard of can
do that American Indians if they're
holding a rod they can tell there's
water underground something rod and he
wasn't Native America and he was just
white dude just a white dude this is an
impressive that's supposed to be like
impress you yes okay and this is
something that like runs in his family
like being able to hold this rod and
sense if there's water underground so I
was like huh so already I was kind of
like alright this will definitely be our
only date then he called me back to tell
me I could never see me again because he
checked out some of my movies I've been
in a lot of horror movies and he said I
can't date anybody that would be on
quote-unquote those kind of movies I was
like what movies you also do these she
does these gay comedy movies called the
eating out movies which sound like
lesbian porn but they are are there
funny movies for gay men yeah that are
not porn you're not even naked in those
movies correct right but I was like I
don't even know if that means but not
like I wanted to go out with Meghan
anyway but yeah thought it was like so
weird someone rejects you that you
aren't even into by the way I was like
I'm not into you [ __ ] captain like
water underground dude Wow yeah that
happened to me with Patti Stanger I
never even told this story on here Patti
Stanger who's the Millionaire Matchmaker
I did whole podcast I used to be on
another podcast network and she was on
it and I did her product amazing and
when I did it afterward she was like how
are you single you're so beautiful and
funny and intelligent and I just I have
to find someone for you I'm gonna find
someone for you so I forgot all about it
six months later I get a call from her
she's like it's Kate it's Patti I have a
guy for you I need you by the way this
is the best part I need you to send me
your best photos your most professional
photos and links to your website and I'm
like photos and links to my website I go
who's the guy and she cuz I can't tell
you till he approves you right and I go
I don't think I'm really interested
she's like fine just google him here's
his name but don't tell anyone don't
contact him I'll send him all your info
so I googled a guy he wasn't even my
type he's like a Ryan Seacrest type like
really pretty kind of effeminate not my
thing so I didn't even follow up I never
sent her anything and then like three
weeks later she messages me and she goes
hey Kate so bad news um he liked your
photos but then he watched him your
material and you're just too dirty for
his public image people would know no
he's on like he's on a TV show that I'd
never even heard of any typos
no but that's the worst thing you get
rejected and you're like I didn't even
want him right oh my god I can't believe
you heard that from like a matchmaker
like he checked out your videos like
it's a casting call I mean that is
essentially what she's doing that's
crazy I know and then part of me was
like [ __ ] this guy and then the other
part of me was like maybe I should try
to get him like that's the girl in me
make him go out with me now I do that
with comedy clubs I'll call you know
most comedy clubs either call me or I
called them yeah every once while
there's one that won't take me and
that's the one I want in even though I
know it's [ __ ] money and [ __ ] [ __ ]
Club I'm still hounding them every year
going you know yeah well we all know
like no no it's not good no one likes to
be rejected right now it is interesting
though because that's comics it's like I
can be rejected on stage meaning like I
try and you hear it doesn't work I'm
against these people who gives a [ __ ]
but when you're rejected personally it
hurts yeah you get over like bombing on
stage when i choke bombs for just like
it means nothing but then like in real
life yeah it turns and it's the same
with vulnerability I can be so
vulnerable on stage I can tell people my
deepest darkest insecurities but unlike
a unlike a date or even two friends I'm
like I don't want them to know this
there should I say on stage that I don't
want people to know and then you're
shocked when like they come up here
anyway well you guys were [ __ ]
amazing guy thank you you guys are so
awesome I want to give you one more
chance oh by the way when you're in
Denver yes yes this is this is big I'm
gonna hit this girl up if you can guess
list her I'm sure she'll love to come
out what do you want this chick who
lives in Denver came to see me at the
Laugh Factory last night her name's
Tiffany Wray I want to give her a
shout-out because she came to see me the
Laugh Factory and she brought me a
birthday present she brought me Rams
pint glasses and flowers Tiffany ray her
name is Tiffany ray so you guys all have
two hits you can come to our show if
you're listening I hope please do we'll
get you as many tickets as you want hit
me up at Dante at Comic Dante calm da
nte at Comic Dante calm of course yes
whoo as many as many tickets as you want
thank you
it's amazing and follow both these guys
on Twitter
Dante yours is at Dante the comment
correct yep and Rebecca at Rebecca
coaching but we have to spell it because
it's complicated is it sorry Bek aah koc
Haan and can I tell him to check out our
website anything you want all right
check out our website it's golden
artists with an S artists
entertainment.com we have I manage a
bunch of people we book comedians and we
also make movies and stuff and right now
our company is producing the biggest
comedy contest in Los Angeles all right
it's called the funniest comic in LA
contest look it up at golden artists
yeah and you can sign up now and Co
check us out at the Denver improv the
20th through the 23rd and in Reno at the
Laugh Factory the 27th of December
through January 1st and whatever yes and
guys if you're listening from Las Vegas
I will be in Vegas with Steve Byrne
December 28th through the 30th I know
it's gonna be so fun and I will also
beat the dirty at 12:30 December 30th
which we were talking about earlier at
Southpoint casinos so make sure you guys
come out and check that and of course
follow me at Kate cue funny I recently
posted a video of me ballet dancing
naked for my birthday which was like are
you really doing you really do it naked
I really did it naked and I do want to
say that I covered my lady parts with
duct tape because I didn't have duct
tape and then people thought that that
was pubes so now everybody keeps deeming
me like great Bush okay so hot by the
way
I thought that was your hot touch that I
was saying I was like is that her doing
actually my butt is like so jiggly and
white in it but I supposed to be funny
I have a very wide ass but um so go to
my Instagram and you can see that @kq
funny
you guys are awesome thanks for
listening as always this is Dave fails
and we'll see you next week bye
[Music]